you know when something's so good you
just don't want it to end that's how we
feel about john party he's back with a
special treat as promised john pardee's
performing his number one hit you've
heard it the single last night lonely
it's from his new album mr saturday
night we apologize john for vlad now
it's your turn guys to do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah your last first kiss we do this
[Music]
yeah the last girl that i take back home
mama the last time that you talk about
this small town drama it's gonna be last
night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the last time giving your heart away to
someone else
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
last
lastly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
yeah
awesome that was awesome thank you thank
you thank you
that's how you start the day john party
that's how you start today
thank you terry thank you
thank you thank you billy maxwell's
amazing but i won't hold it against you
thank you matt thank you lisa yeah
pantomime of the yeah
yes yes that's the best line in the song
happy anniversary to us thank you so
much thank you thank you for helping us
celebrate really appreciate it awesome
can you come back tomorrow
let's make it a regular thing you good
with these hours yeah
and if you can't
just hours yeah i can see it in your
eyes you like getting up early
we like having you here that'll do it
for us unfortunately we gotta go all
good things come new end we'll see you
tomorrow on cbs morning
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you